are you kidding me it's breaking
is that the hint
to tell me i'm wrong hey guys it's katie
and welcome back to another episode of
lost in translation if this is your
first time here we take a recipe we put
it into google translate it goes from
english to malay to hungarian to german
and many many many more until it's
finally back to english to give us a
hilariously translated recipe i like to
call this series let's torture jasmine
let's just get in there and just keep
putting her on the spot
[Music]
are you excited i'm so excited this
one's fun maybe you'll know it
cat papyrus
i
can't even tell if it's sweet or savory
you're gonna have to find out let's make
cat papyrus step one warm to 350 degrees
cover with the small oven plate
i'm gonna preheat the oven to 350. i'll
be right back cover with the small oven
plate i am going to grab a baking sheet
i want to say it's one of these
i'm gonna go with this one
i am just taking a shot in the dark
step number two put a small one-third
glass of milk into a small bowl and melt
so now i'm thinking glasses cup milk is
either milk heavy whipping cream or
butter i think melt could be like warm
or heat
why do i trust milk oh there's a lot of
milk a third cup of milk is so little
all right you have five seconds five
four three two butter
all right we got a third cup of butter
let's go microwave this step three
dissolve six yolks
a third cup of lard and half cup of
sugar in a bowl i think i might need to
crack some eggs so i'll just prepare
this for now i'm thinking lard is either
butter oh
this is from the last step the third cup
of lard
yes
i think sugar is sugar all right so i
did six eggs it says yolks so i am going
to remove the yolks why did you purse
your lips i just thought it was funny
how you uh did it this way i'm trying to
buy time here and now we're gonna move
on to a third cup of lard i think it's
the lard that i just melted and now i'm
gonna add half a cup of sugar so
dissolve i think that just means to
combine step number four carefully pour
it into yolk
maybe now i pour this into my egg whites
i think i need a hint kelly may i have a
hint you're missing that comes from a
cow no
i need milk i'm just gonna go warm this
in the microwave and now i'm gonna pour
it into my
yolk slowly so i don't get scrambled
eggs so are you worried about that
butter you put in now
i wasn't
baking requires extreme precision and if
i've messed it up flavors and textures
will
the sugar is dissolved let's move on to
the next step step number five in bowl
cut one cup bread crumbs to mix gently
there's bread crumbs whole wheat pastry
flour do you think that you're getting
any better at this
i think it's flour there's pastry flour
cake flour i think it's cake flour i am
going to sift one cup of cake flour into
my mixture i should have used a bigger
bowl that's a t-shirt we're gonna need
it bigger
now i'm just gonna mix gently step
number six in a separate bowl whisk six
egg whites in a quarter glass of hard
sugar until a solid hole is found
i think a solid hole is a stiff peak how
did you get a solid hole to stiff peaks
hole
dip dip valley valley peak i'm gonna
start whisking my egg whites and slowly
add my sugar while i'm doing that until
stiff peaks form
all right step number seven cut the egg
whites into cubes and turn the dough i'm
gonna take my egg whites into cubes and
turn it into my dough right now it feels
like i'm making a cake confidence level
is like a solid
so i'm gonna continue to
i'm feeling good so far i'm excited to
eat some sort of cake step number eight
distribute the dough evenly on the
prepared deck my prepared deck
oh well step one cover my small plate
with parchment paper
i'm gonna bring on my deck however it is
unprepared so i shall prepare it and now
i'm just going to add in my dough and
distribute it evenly next step step
number nine cook for 12 to 15 minutes
until completely dissolved the cake must
be one year old cook for 12 to 15
minutes i think is baked for 12 to 15
minutes the cake should rest for one
hour
maybe it's baked for one hour
we're gonna take this prepared deck and
we're gonna cook it for 12 to 15 minutes
and then it'll be one year old let's
move on to step 10. relax for five to
seven minutes then wipe off the paper
using a kitchen towel pull the cake out
of the morgue start small
stir for 15 minutes first step is to
relax for five to seven minutes we're
gonna do that for five to seven minutes
you guys having a good day
wipe off the paper remove the parchment
paper so i am going to flip this stir
for 15 minutes i have messed up
somewhere i will need a hint katie the
pan
you chose
may have been incorrect no
is that the hint
to tell me i'm wrong so i guess it was
supposed to be a sheet tray which means
it would have been a lot thinner what
i'm gonna do is take a knife and
thinner i have split my baby into two
i'm gonna take a kitchen towel and i am
going to roll it up it doesn't say to do
this but thinking about what i did in
strawberry king king i am going to take
some powdered sugar and glue it on my
towel all right and now i'm gonna roll
it up being very careful here look at it
stir for 15 minutes means let it stay
rolled i'm gonna put this in the fridge
step eleven in large bowl mix one cup
sour cream
two tablespoon sugar half teaspoon bean
mix hands into smooth rough mountains
[Laughter]
i could do large bowl mix 1 cup sour
cream is it sour cream
i think sugar could definitely be sugar
sour cream i think it could be
mascarpone what's this
vanilla bean
bean ribbons
dude there's
all pepero i'm deciding that my one cup
of sour cream is one cup of mascarpone
two tablespoons of powdered sugar i am
going with vanilla bean for half
teaspoon bean i'm just gonna mix this
into rough mountains step number 12 peel
cut and squeeze the juice remove the
kitchen towel and add the watermelon
berries to the dough
i'm getting vibes that it should be
lemon
i think this is the dough i think
berries is strawberries watermelon water
water glass glass drink drink straw
straw berries
i'm str apricot jam only a friend could
save me
from the mistake i might make
no one's gonna save you i have put a
lemon in my squeezer and now i'm just
gonna do a little bit it doesn't say how
much which is why i feel like this could
be wrong remove the kitchen towel
and add the watermelon berries to the
dough oh
this
all right i need a hint you have a
special hint today actually mimo
is gonna facetime you whenever you need
her oh my god making her work on
vacation
time to call nemo
nemo
[Music]
hi
how's it going can you help me remove
the kitchen towel and add the watermelon
berries to the dough watermelon berries
is confusing me oh
all right so when you're driving home
you're stuck in traffic you're stuck in
traffic
jam
thank you i love you bye have fun on
vacation
bye so it's jam but what kind of jam i'm
gonna do strawberry i'm just gonna do a
thin even layer on both sides that is
done
step number 13 wrap the cake in fresh
parchment paper cook for 10 minutes
are you kidding me i'm just gonna roll
it back up and then i'm gonna chill it
for 10 minutes
it's breaking i don't know what to say
it's breaking
okay okay okay we're just going to move
quickly yeah yeah just don't go slow i
think parchment means plastic so i'm
going to wrap this up i'm going to go
put this in the fridge for 10 minutes
step number 14 cut the dough into 12
tablespoons cut my cake into 12 slices
is this strawberry king king it's cat
papyrus you're right
let's get this baby out of here and
we're just gonna cut this into 12 equal
slices okay i'm going to cut this in
half and then split those into three
look how pretty it is it broke but it's
okay 12 tablespoons step number 15 place
the cake on the spiral pan
apply the cream evenly to the scalp add
a pinch of crab to three layers and
repeat
refrigerate for five minutes
how is this not strawberry
[Music]
i think i'm gonna go with this one i am
going to take these spirals and i'm
going to put them in my spiral pan now
it's on one layer three layers and
repeat
three layers this isn't right
i'm gonna remove this oh you know what
change of plans three layers so each
layer will have four of these guys one
two three four apply cream evenly to the
scalp so each layer will have a little
spoon of cream this is probably wrong
because this is spreading not very fun
layer two
and then we're doing another layer of
cream on our scalp we got our third
layer this is cute
final layer this looks good refrigerate
for five minutes step 16 pour a cup of
chocolate into quarter cup of hot cream
leave the bag outside i think we're
gonna make some chocolate coating
i think hot cream is heavy whipping
cream so i'll do a quarter cup of that
and just for a cup of chocolate i think
that could be chocolate chips semi-sweet
morsels dark chocolate milk chocolate i
am going to go with dark chocolate
morsels i'm just gonna mix this until
it's all melted step 17 add the cake to
the chocolate filling sprinkle the chill
on the wall i think filling i think i'm
gonna cover my cake with this chocolate
filling i have decided i am going to
transfer this onto a wire rack here
very carefully
now i'm going to pour my chocolate sauce
this looks delicious now i'm just going
to spread this i am really loving how
this is turning out sprinkle the chill
on the wall the chill sprinkles
oh there's gold
gold all right we're gonna do gold on
the side and we're just gonna do it
along the entire outside i am done
adding my gold on the side have i gone a
little overboard absolutely but that's
because cat papyrus has a big
personality step 18 serve the cake with
one cup chopped strawberries and pesto i
think i am going to chop up some
strawberries add it to the top
pistachios
so i am just going to sprinkle this on
top here and then finally i think pesto
is pistachios step 19 final step pick up
the red line and throw the cake i think
it means to
transfer to plate and throw the cake
now i'm gonna transfer this cake to this
plate wish me luck
[Laughter]
my fingers are cramping
now for this side wow
throw the cake
are you ready to see what it looks like
yeah
open your eyes
that is beautiful it's peppero cake for
peppero day in korea sort of like
valentine's day it's common for people
to gift these cakes i'm familiar with
this cake you are familiar with this day
i did not make the connection at all
it is a thin biscuit that is coated in
chocolate and you can get it in
different flavors let's give this a try
mmm
not too sweet the chocolate ganache is
chef's kiss i'm not gonna lie i'm really
into cat papyrus but let's give the
pepero cake a try cheers
the cake is very nice and fluffy the
pepero adds like a very nice beautiful
crunch would you guys like to try cat
papyrus
mmm that's good i like it it's good
[Music]
this was so much fun cat papyrus was
delicious we have more episodes coming
out so make sure your notification bell
is turned on and we got an exciting
guest next week who i i don't know who
it is so stay tuned
thanks guys bye
so this is what i do
i scrape it like this
and then once it's there i go
oh there's spheres cocktail shrimp
do you drink butter sometimes i'm just
kidding me oh sorry
[Laughter]
she's like not on vacation
[Music]
you